jean françois lépine j'aurais dit
spécialisé en affaires internationales
jean-françois ancien directeur des
représentations du québec en chine
bonsoir jean françois bossler patrice
est ce que les chinois d'après vous vont
refaire un tour de manège de leur colère
envers le canada ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à des représailles
sens qu'il va y avoir en tout cas des
réactions négatives maintenant il faut
imaginer là que la chine actuellement
est débordé de problème
l'aco vide d'une crise majeure dans tout
le pays la guerre en ukraine qui dans
lequel la chine s'est positionné et qui
lui a beaucoup nui à travers le monde et
puis l'économie chinoise qui en
conséquence de ces deux phénomènes la
est en recul ça va pas bien il ya aussi
des élections qui s'en viennent au sein
du parti communiste chinois pour
l'obtention de la part du président si
d'un troisième mandat donc à une
situation là on a on aurait dit
peut-être que le canada peut être
attendre vu cette situation là
délibérément c'est peut-être pas vrai
pour faire cette annonce là mais c'est
sûr que la chine a d'autres
préoccupations
et elle a surtout une préoccupation
importante elle a perdu dans son appui à
la guerre à l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine elle a perdu beaucoup la
confiance de l'europe des états unis
donc de ses deux principaux partenaires
économiques
elle peut pas beaucoup la chine se payer
le luxe de se mettre à dos un autre pays
en adoptant des mesures qui c'est
extraordinaire il faut dire patrice une
chose qui est assez inouï encore une
fois ça fait parti d'un de du contexte
mais hier pas plus tard qu'hier la chine
annonçait que les restrictions qui
avaient été imposées
quelques mois après l'arrestation de
madame en one jo sur le les importations
chinoises de graines de canola du canada
et que ces restrictions la donc
dorénavant vont tomber donc les
importations de canola vont pouvoir
atteindre leur niveau normal d'avant
l'arrestation de madame davant ces
mesures qui avaient été adoptées en 2019
donc il ya un contexte là qui vous
illustre à quel point les chinois ont
besoin ces temps-ci d'ouvrir les vannes
plutôt que d'y fermer à jean-françois
avant de vous laisser sur le fond de
l'histoire sur les craintes que les
occidentaux que lente que les 5 g les
pays que je ne mets plus tôt en face à
huawei est ce que ça c'est largement
admis c'est presque une évidence pour
plusieurs qui reconnaissent la chaîne
que huawei aurait pu se servir de ça
technologies pour faire de l'espionnage
oui ça n'a pas empêché beaucoup de pays
d'utiliser la technologie et les
services de roi ou et même certains pays
en europe mais la plupart des pays qui
ont qui partagent nos valeurs et surtout
qui partagent nos préoccupations de
sécurité ont adopté des mesures contre
et oubliez pas l' annonce d'aujourd'hui
porte sur les technologies et les
services de roy oui mais aussi de zte
qui est une immense compagnie chinoise
dans la même ville à shenzhen qui a
probablement les mêmes liens avec
l'armée chinoise avec la sécurité
l'univers de la cybersécurité en chine
elle aussi cette compagnie lot grand
fournisseur de technologies de services
dans les systèmes de communication 5
j'ai fait des affaires cette compagnie
là un peu partout dans le monde aussi
est coté en bourse à l'étranger cette
compagnie là et cibler aussi donc c'est
c'est vraiment une préoccupation je
pense deux pays qui partagent les mêmes
encore une fois les mêmes valeurs sur le
plan de la sécurité et de l'ouverture de
communication et c'est important de le
noter comme ça mais il faut imaginer
aussi que roy oui je pense que vous
l'avez évoqué un peu plus tôt va
continuer ses activités au canada non
seulement dans la vente de ces appareils
téléphoniques mais froid oui a été
accepté au canada depuis des années
comme une entreprise qui fait de la
recherche au canada en collaboration
avec les meilleures universités
canadiennes polytechnique à montréal par
exemple ou croit ou et un centre de
recherche importants à kanata près
d'ottawa avec d'ancien régime qui a été
lancé avec d'anciens ingénieurs de
nortel donc voix ou est très présent
aussi dans la recherche au canada c'est
comme ça qu'on a pu aussi évaluer les
systèmes et 10 rebonds huawei en sait
trop je n'en sais trop moi non plus mais
il reste quoi vous êtes un citoyen
d'affaires canadien maintenant connus et
sa décision n'a été prise en
connaissance de cause et les choix vont
faire attention aussi de ne pas non plus
gâcher voilà les relations futures ou
les projets futurs de roy oui avec le
canada mais comme vous le dites si bien
jean françois ils en ont plein les bras
avec des réelles que la coved à chandra
et on a parlé un québécois qui vit à
shanghai il ya quelques jours
cette politique de covè 2 0 qui la
pression est insoutenable exactement à
pékin aussi maintenant de plus en plus
et dans une quarantaine de villes de
chine actuellement jean-françois les
peines toujours un plaisir merci
beaucoup à bientôt bienvenue patrice
voix pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit